he is pro Football Hall of Famer himself
now my friend from NFL Network gameday
morning Kurt Warner how are you Kurt I'm
good buddy how are you I'm fine
did you know Anquan was wavering about
playing football Kurt I knew he was
wavering you know I'd actually had some
conversations with him leading up to the
Hall of Fame because I wanted him to
come down and join me and he was just
contemplating as he went farther and
farther into the offseason and no deal
really done you know whether this was
going to be the time where he decided to
hang it up or not and then I hadn't
really had any conversations with him
since he signed his deal with Buffalo so
knowing that he was wavering and then
signing the deal I kind of thought okay
he's at least going one more year so
haven't really had a chance to talk to
him since he made that decision I texted
me yesterday just congratulated him on a
great career but wasn't fully sure on
what led to this decision after after
signing that contract but I know it's
been hard on him and his family the last
few years as he left Arizona and it
seemed like he was bouncing all over
with different teams and you know and
that's so important to him to make sure
that his family's with him and he gets
to spend time with them and that they're
a priority and so I'm sure a lot of that
played into this decision but but
definitely was surprised after he signed
the contract that he decided to pack it
up and when did you first meet him just
when you strolled in from the Giants
systems a play exactly uh you know I
didn't know a whole lot about him and
you know one of the stories Josh McCown
was a guy new that was here in Arizona
when I came and I was coming from st.
Louis obviously via the stop in New York
and you know and Josh kept texting me
and telling me hey you know ankle you're
going to love aunt Connie's just like
Torrey home and you know Here I am I'm
sitting here with what a future
hall-of-famer and going okay you know
that's high praise but you know I'm
going to I'm going to reserve myself to
really see that because there's not very
many guys that are like Torrey hold and
when I got here I saw exactly what he
was talking about the pro that he was
the ability to do so many different
things
unbelievable competitiveness I don't
know if I ever played with a guy that
was more competitive than Anquan Boldin
it just a pro's Pro and you know it's
funny because we actually had
when I was here so that was however many
years ago seven years ago or more with
Antoine going you know how long in a
play and at that time Antoine was a guy
that was very self-conscious that life
was so much bigger than football and I
remember when he was here thinking you
know he could retire at any moment and
be 100 percent fine some guys you know
it's like this is all I really know I'm
going to play until they kick me out
Anquan I've kind of waited every time
that he's this contract has been up
somewhere I'm texting him like art is
this it and he goes I'm not really sure
yet and so I always appreciated that
about it because he was very conscious
of the community and his family and
things beyond football that he loved
football and love to compete and was
gifted to do it but it was never the
thing that you know that drove him to
the point where he had to do it and so
I've been waiting for this you know this
moment for a long time going okay he'll
go back and play or he won't and he's
going to be 100% fine either way and it
won't surprise me either way
you know and that just kind of the guy
he was and so I look forward to seeing
what he does next because he's not going
to be the guy that sits on his couch
he's going to go out and make a
difference to continue to make a
difference across the country and I'm
excited to see what what he chooses to
do next Kurt Warner here on the Rich
Eisen show that competitive spirit of
just thinking about his career that
moment where he kind of went at Todd
Haley your offensive coordinators right
in the middle of a playoff run that
wound up in the Super Bowl Kurt right I
mean that would you would you point to
that and say that that's the sort of
stuff you're referring to yeah I mean
that kind of stuff you know it was one
of those situations where we had a
certain grouping in and you know was
late in the game and you know he was
running around so we pulled him out and
you know he was just one of those guys
that when the games on the line he wants
the ball in his hands and he wants to be
on the field you know and he's
competitive he's fiery you watched him
play he was tough he was physical so
that was the kind of attitude that he
brought no matter what he was doing and
so you know what I got into it with Todd
on the sidelines every once in a while
so if I could get into it with Todd Todd
was a little bit fiery too so they were
definitely those moments with Ankara but
it was just a competitiveness that give
me the ball put me on the field I make
our team better when we're out there and
it's so much what I loved about him and
I loved playing with him because of it
and you know the great thing was is he's
one of those guys that everybody would
watch him year in and year out and they
would say oh he's replaceable you know
he's not the fast guys he's not this
he's not that
and I watched team after team say we can
replace him yet nobody is able to
replace an Anquan Boldin when we lost
him in Arizona there was no replacing
him he goes to the next team and leads
them in receptions then he goes to the
next team and went leads them in
receptions and he does it throughout his
entire career and it just speaks to you
know when you know him that's the Pro
that I'm talking about is you can bring
in 10 guys that are quote unquote more
talented than him you won't find a
better Pro you won't find one that knows
how to play the game better and you
won't find one more competitive so
you'll never be able to replace that guy
even though team after team after team
tried because what they saw with their I
didn't always calculate but as we know
risk that's kind of the business isn't
it they look with their eye and think
that always dictates the football
players but Anquan Boldin was one of the
most special football players I was ever
ever around well I mean and you know we
talked about it earlier on the show in
the same way that I talked about it when
he got signed with the Buffalo Bills I
think he is a Pro Football Hall of Famer
I mean he has numbers that are up there
do you think that he is I don't think
there's any question and again I speak
to what I know the problem with it is
just like you know you look at the
numbers and I agree with you numbers
speak for themselves but another guy
like Isaac Bruce who I believe belongs
in the Hall of Fame quiet unspoken guy
you know a soft-spoken guy that doesn't
say a whole lot doesn't garner the
attention that he deserves because he's
not one of those flamboyant guys yet
everything about him says Hall of Famer
same to me with Anquan Boldin is that
you sometimes look at the physical
things and say oh maybe he doesn't quite
look like a hall-of-famer but when you
watch him play when you play with him
you just say that guy special that guy
is different and the numbers to me
bear it out and I've always said to me
what makes guys even more special is
guys that go from team to team to team
and put up the same kind of numbers and
lead a new team because that's very
difficult to do to move someplace find a
home you know find yourself you know
comfortable in a new system and be able
to excel when you're bouncing from one
place to another and that's what I saw
Han Kuang do is he went he made every
team he was with better he made every
quarterback he was with better and you
let every team he was with interceptions
and yards and any stacks up in the top
15 of all time so to me it's a
no-brainer but unfortunately some people
might just see okay he doesn't quite
match up physically with some of these
other guys and put that as a strike
against him where I'd step back and look
at and say that to me should be a strike
for him that says even though maybe he
didn't possess exactly what these you
know elite athletes possess in certain
ways he more than made up for with the
player that he was and the way he
competed and played this game and that
to me adds more to his resume and I hope
one day that that he slips on a gold
jacket is up on that stage with me well
I mean a couple more minutes here with
Kurt Warner here's the deal is that in
Arizona there was my Fitzgerald who was
a bonafide first-ballot hall-of-famer
when he was in Baltimore when he won the
Super Bowl when he scored the first
touchdown for the Ravens in that Super
Bowl the star of that team was
essentially the defense right so there
was Ray and there's Eddie so there's
always been that other shining light
that everyone's been focusing on while
he's toiled and then when you talk about
the special moment that people recall
for their career and I know this is
something that you don't really like to
talk about a lot Kurt people bring up
the fact that he had his face broken in
many different spots and he came back
and I know you threw him the pass and
that was a very emotional moment for you
and your family as well would you walk
us through the courage I guess that he
that that that Anquan had or possessed
there in that moment that me there's so
many different things I saw his
competitiveness every single day I saw
his toughness every single day you know
I saw the way he competed
and the way you know physically he
dominated football games but that
sequence was I mean it was like nothing
you've ever seen before to see what he
went through to understand the depth of
those injuries and the position that he
plays where you know you have to trust
the guys around you and you know you
have to put yourself in those situations
with no fear to be able to play that
position the way that he did and so to
go through that sequence you know and as
you said that nobody really understands
how hard that was on me I know if it was
that hard on me how much more difficult
that had to be on Antoine and his family
and the people around him and to see his
unwavering commitment to come back how
quickly he was able to to conquer those
fears in that situation and come back
and help our team you know there was 52
guys in our locker room that watched
that guy in awe and were inspired by
what that guy did to get back on the
field and what he put on the line for
all of us and again a lot of people
might see that as the football player I
see that as the person in the character
that underlies all of that but it was I
mean it was incredible to watch that and
as I said we were all inspired and
wanted to battle for that guy as much as
anybody because we watched what you know
what he did and what he put on the line
for each and every one of us before I
let you go put on your game day morning
hat we've got some quarterbacks
including the one who through bold and
all those passes in Baltimore Joe Flacco
he's not even up an act of practicing
hasn't thrown a pass but is back and
you've got cam who didn't play this week
again and Andrew Luck who the heck knows
when we see him again how concerned
should everybody be that these guys are
not going to be ready for week one uh
fully concerned you know because because
we know it gets to this point and every
quarterback that feels like they're in a
position
play are going to be out there playing
and competing and you know even if
they're trying to save them for a week
one I'm worried for that standpoint you
know worried that you don't get any reps
and you're missing all of this time and
think you're going to be that guy when
you step between the lines game one and
if you can't go out and practice and
throw everything right now then you know
what makes me think that you're going to
get through 16 games being able to play
at that level and take the hits and do
the things that you're going to have to
do you know they go through an NFL
season so I'm fully concerned about all
those guys the farther this thing goes
the more concerned I am that they're not
going to be there and B if they're there
how long is it going to take them to get
up to speed because what we know is
every game is extremely important and if
you fall behind the eight ball early it
is tough to make those games up so if
I'm those things I'm fully concerned
right now especially with some of the
questions at the backup spot that you
have as well it's not like you have you
know this solid guy sitting behind them
and go okay you know he can suffice for
three or four weeks if need be I think
all those teams are in situations where
you're really wondering what you're
going to have and what you're going to
be with with the guy behind the card two
weeks from tomorrow's our game day
morning season preview show then it's
time let's go why don't you working on
your Super Bowl prediction you got huh
yeah I'll I'm sure I'll have it ready
okay so I'll put a lot of time into this
and make sure because you're looking
this year Kurt I kind of get like this
I'm defending my cousin I'm so scared
Kurt I'm defending my championship we
you know we let you win last year right
I am thoroughly in the dark on that like
the solar eclipse right sorry we like it
better when you think that you know I
look really okay Kurt love you man we'll
see I said Pakistan has crippled the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on radio stations across the country and
audience
if you like that please download our app
there's lots of fun things there other
than just more of the videos you just
saw you can call us from the app you can
email us from the app just download it
trust me you'll enjoy